just be yourself has become sort of a
statement that people venerate these
days people celebrate just be yourself
probably because it kind of feels like a
warm hug just be yourself and
everything's gonna be okay it feels kind
of empathetic understanding it's like
yeah you're right i can just be myself
that sounds fantastic i don't have to be
anything that i'm not just be yourself
feels like it really cares about you
despite the fact that nobody really
follows that advice because you can't
really follow it everybody is a
chameleon of sorts when you're around
the boys having a beer you're going to
act way differently than you do when
you're around your mom when you're at a
job interview you're going to be all
proper and professional and maybe a
little bit personable way more charming
than you would if you're just relaxing
on the couch devolving into degeneracy
or trying to watch something on netflix
we do this because we kind of have to
different situations that we're in
recruit different parts of us different
emphases sometimes we have to be
professional other times we have to be
very charming and funny like i'm doing
right now i'm not like this in real life
but i've got to film a better ideas
video so i sound super smart and
personable and relatable the point i'm
trying to make is that are we ever
really ourselves
what does it mean to be ourselves and is
it something that we should strive to be
because just be yourself has become
something that we've been conditioned to
believe is true based on repetition
maybe the walt disney company got us all
believing that we should just be
ourselves make our dreams come true
follow our heart find our passion all of
these bubble gum cotton candy birthday
card sentiments that all sound very
comforting but don't really mean
anything and are impossible to just
apply to your life we hear these things
so often they've become utterly
meaningless like nobody's life was ever
changed by somebody saying to them hey
just follow your dreams you know
what does that mean i've had some pretty
[ __ ] up dreams in my day and if we
were to follow those dreams we would all
be screwed god help us all and follow
your passion like most people that you
talk to have no idea what their passion
is they have things they're interested
in probably a bunch of things they're
interested in but there's a lot of
pressure in like oh find your passion
and everything's going to work out
there's a lot of pressure in that
because people get analysis paralysis
they have no idea which passion to pick
what's going to be the one thing that
makes everything make sense and again i
think that we tend to agree with these
tag lines not because they're
particularly instructional but because
they sound like they mean well they're
very easy to swallow it's never
challenging or uncomfortable to believe
that the answer to all of our problems
is to just be more of ourselves whatever
that means but i think that just being
yourself is inherently a defeatist
statement because just implies that
yourself is something to just be it's a
reality to regress back to it tells you
to stop reaching and stop pursuing and
just be you because you're just you it's
an inherently pessimistic statement
veiled in
self-congratulation a statement that
doesn't want the best for you a
statement that doesn't care about your
ideals your conception of a brighter
future it's a statement that encourages
you to stop growing but riddle me this
why just be yourself when you can be so
much more now you might think to
yourself well i can only just be myself
right if i'm always striving to be more
than myself then i will never feel okay
with myself i'll never feel comforted
i'll never feel okay with who i am and
instead i will hold this future version
of myself in front of me like a carrot
to a mule hamster wheeling myself i
guess mule mule wheeling yourself right
into your grave you know you'll never be
able to stop and smell the roses you'll
always be looking for the next thing
goals and goals and goals and you'll be
searching for a piece that you could
find in the present moment and while i
understand this argument i also think
it's very short-sighted it doesn't take
into account the bigger picture of the
human brain and that is that yes we do
need to feel satisfied and happy with
what we have that's what serotonin and
oxytocin and endorphins are for you know
they're all for feeling good in the
present moment it's a very important
system of our psychology but potentially
way more influential and important for
our survival is our dopamine system and
dopamine is all about motivation if
somebody were to delete all the dopamine
in your brain right now so you couldn't
feel a lick of dopamine you would lay
down in whatever chair you're sitting on
because you probably not have the
motivation to sit down and you would
never lift a finger to do anything you
would pee your pants because you
wouldn't be motivated to go to the
bathroom you wouldn't get up to eat
anything you would literally lay there
and die we need motivation to go get
things that we don't already have it's
the only reason why you're alive right
now so in a way motivation is the desire
to attain something that we don't
already have it's something that
requires us to move in space and time to
go get and that will never go away right
we will always be motivated to do
something the question is what are we
locking our motivation into is it
netflix is it social media is it buying
frivolous things
no judgment but i'm just saying that
it's locked into something so since we
have this profound desire to achieve
things that we haven't already achieved
or to get things that we don't already
have what better thing is there to lock
our motivation system into
then being the best version of ourselves
so that we can be more capable people
capable of helping ourselves get through
the hardships of life so that we can
help others get through the hardships in
their lives essentially making the world
a better place through being the best we
can be so i think that two things can be
true at the same time we can both strive
for greatness and be the best that we
can be
not settling for just being ourselves
but at the same time having honesty and
compassion for wherever we are now but a
lot of the time we have very weird
tendencies and behaviors that we think
are just a part of who we are but in
fact they are behaviors that we learned
through trauma or the role that we
played in our friends group or our
family that lead us to do things that
don't actually serve us they don't serve
others and all in all they're just a net
negative even though it's like oh it's
just that's just me haha like you'd be
surprised how many aspects of your
personality
are improvable you know you might think
that it's just a little quirk or
insanity that you have
but consider the fact that you can
improve it you can modify your behavior
and your thought patterns to better
serve you and things that you previously
thought were just part of your
personality or you being you
are things that are just a result of the
way you are brought up and things that
don't actually help you in the long run
don't get self-compassion confused with
complacency for instance if you had a
close friend and he kind of went off the
deep end previously you were really good
friends you got along and then he
started to become kind of toxic he
started pushing you and others away
through his behaviors through his words
and you're kind of like what gives this
guy has changed and i don't know if i
want to be around him anymore but i do
really care about him but for now i have
to distance myself if this person were
to come up to you sincerely and say hey
look i realize
my behavior was out of line
i didn't really realize it at the time
but it's become clear to me that i need
to change
my words and my actions are hurting me
or hurting others and i'm ready to
change would you say no it's okay just
be yourself you do you you'd probably
say i agree your behavior was out of
line
i'm so glad that you can see that and
since i care about you i really want to
help you be the best version of yourself
so that you can serve yourself better
and you know get along with everybody
right i want you to be the best you can
be
and it's funny because
loving that person isn't just permitting
them to do their thing and be who they
are and whatever that's complacency
since you care about that person you
want to help them be the best version of
themselves i truly believe that we need
to treat ourselves like this we need to
treat ourselves like we have inherent
dignity like we're on our own side and
we want the best for ourselves and a lot
of the time we don't treat ourselves
with the dignity that we deserve our
behaviors and our actions or maybe
habits or ways of thinking or thought
patterns that we have that we've had
since the dawn of time as long as we can
remember
are proving with time to not serve us to
be destructive maybe we learned these
tendencies through childhood and they're
just a part of who we are but they're
leading us to the brink of doom we gain
no traction in our lives like nothing's
working should we just be ourselves then
so ask yourself are you living a life
that reflects your inherent dignity are
your thoughts behaviors and habits
serving you who do you ideally want to
be and what can you do to help you
become somebody of strength and the
bizarre thing is when we start caring
more about our future when we have
ideals when we have something to strive
towards we actually start to become more
satisfied with the present moment and
especially when you've been on that path
for a little while you can look to your
past and you have a track record of
growth you can be comforted that you've
come a long way and you can be excited
and motivated by the person that you're
becoming
self-satisfaction can't exist in a
vacuum it's impossible to shake our
concept of the true the good and the
beautiful so maybe the answer to life
isn't to just be yourself maybe the
answer is to love yourself enough to
become something more
a big thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video you guys know that
ag-1 is by far my favorite supplement on
the entire planet it just makes me feel
so good throughout the day i almost
can't believe it packed with over 75
vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods and adaptogens in every
single scoop ag-1 is like the mother
lode of nutrition for your body and
because the ingredients are sourced from
real foods it has a high degree of
bioavailability which means that your
body doesn't just urinate it out it can
actually soak in and your body can
deploy it in its various systems so i'd
highly recommend joining me in this
daily habit that i do every single day
that i've been doing for about two years
so if you use my link in the description
below athletic greens is hooking you
guys up with a year's supply of the
vitamin d3 and k2 complex which i also
have every single morning as well as
five ag-1 travel packs with your first
purchase so make sure you take advantage
of that offer by clicking on my link in
the description below join me on the
quest for body and mental dominance and
thank you athletic greens for sponsoring
this video if you liked this video then
actually hit the like button because
that's always a huge help it helps the
video rank better it shoves my bald head
into other people's home pages helping
them out which helps me out so it's a
win-win for everybody if you're lurking
here and this is the billionth time that
you've seen my face or watched one of my
videos consider subscribing i don't
think it does anything i don't think it
i don't know maybe the algorithm likes
it or something other than that thank
you so much for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video